نظام الينا من كيا فيوري ساك مستشار وزيره
الدفاع الاوكراني والمتحدث باسمي وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه اهلا بك سيد جوري
صواريخ اذن اوكرانيه محليه الصنع يبلغ
مداها 700 كلم متى باعتقادك ستدخل ساحه
المعركه والى اي مدى تعول عليها كياف في
المعارك
طابع مسائكم نعم حقيقه نحن فخورون بان
نستطيع بنجاح اختبار
الصواريخ في الحقيقه مداها هو الف كيلو
متر لكن الاختبارات التي تمت يوم امس
اختبرناها ل 700 كيلومتر فقط وهو جزء من
برنامج
صواريخ طويله المدى ونعمل في اطلاق
الانتاج الجماعي لها في اقرب وقت تحت
رعايه رئيس الجمهوريه ووزاره الدفاع وهذا
سيكون انجازا مهما لاوكرانيا طبعا في
الوقت الذي نتلقى فيه بكل امتنان دعم
حلفائنا العسكري لكننا في ذات الوقت
نطور قاعدتنا الصناعيه العسكريه
فلدينا مسيراتنا التي ننتج
برنامج الصواريخ بعيده المدى ايضا ونعمل
ان نحقق اكتفاء ذاتيا في ذلك في المستقبل
نحن نعرف ان روسيا دوله معتديه ارهابيه
حتى بعد ان نقسم هذه الحرب لن تختفي من
الوجود فيجب ان نكون
مهيئين للدفاع عن بلادنا وعن القيم
المشتركه لاوروبا ولهذا نحتاج الى قاعده
صناعيه دفاعيه صلبه فيما يتعلق بهذه
الصواريخ بعيده المدى ومحليه الصنع من قبل
اوكرانيا براي كيف ستؤثر على سير المعارك
وهل سيتم استخدامها لضرب العمق الروسي
مازال من المذكر القول متى سنستطيع
استخدام هذه الصواريخ بعيده المدى في
الخطوط الاماميه للقتال لكن نحن على سبيل
المثال نطلب صواريخ بعيده المدى من
شركائنا
لانها مهمه جدا من حيث اعطاء اوكرانيا
القدره على الوصول الى العمق عمق روسيا
المعتديه وايضا الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه
التي تحتلها روسيا مؤقتا طبعا
اعطينا صواريخ فرنسا اعطته
وهي صواريخ طويله المدى نامل من ان
المانيا ستزودنا بصواريخ تونس طويله المدى
ونعملات المتحده سوف تعطينا صواريخ بعيط
لماذا
لكن اكرر اننا نحتاج الى صواريخنا الخاصه
بنا تقول سيدوري
انها لا تشجع ضربات في العمق الروسي
نحن نفهم ان هذه هي اكبر حرب منذ انتهاء
الحرب العالميه الثانيه ونحن نفهم ايضا ان
كثيرا من حلفاءنا يريدون ضمان تفادي اي
تصعيد لهذه الحرب ونحن دائما نقول
لشركائنا امرا بسيطا واحدا وهو هناك
احتمال واحد لتفادي التصعيد ان تستطيع
القوات
الاوكرانيه الحاقه الهزيمه بروسيا ولهذا
نحن نحتاج الى الدعم لهذا السبب حلفائنا
لديهم بواعف قلق وفي كل مره
نتلقى منظومه سياحيه جديده نلتزم علنا
امامهم مؤخرا عندما وافقت الولايات
المتحده على نقل الذخائر العنقوديه لنا
اوضحنا باننا سنستخدمها فقط داخل اوكرانيا
وداخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه المحتله وفقط
لضرب القوات الروسيه الارهابيه ولم تستخدم
باي طريقه اخرى ونبقى ملتزمين بهذا التعهد
شكرا جزيلا لك مستشار وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني والمتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه من كيف